[Music]
get on corrupting issue diphthong I
don't speak those languages in fact very
few people do they're used only by a
handful of people and all those
languages are in danger of extinction
there are more than 7,000 languages
spoken in the world today but about 1/3
of those have fewer than 1000 speakers
and according to UNESCO more than 40% of
those languages are in danger of
extinction in fact every fortnight one
of the world's languages disappears
forever when you say dead language many
people think of Latin but Latin actually
never died it's been spoken continuously
since the time of the Caesars but it
changed very gradually over 2,000 years
until it became French Spanish and other
Romance languages true language death
happens when communities switched to
other languages and parents stopped
raising their children to speak their
old ones when the last elderly speaker
dies the language is unlikely ever to be
spoken fluently again if you look at
this chart which measures the world's
languages in terms of their size and
their state of health you can see that
most languages are ranked in the middle
English like just a few other dominant
languages is up at the top left hand
corner it's in a really strong state but
if your language is down here in the
bottom right hand corner of the graph
like high you pull out from Indonesia or
quitea from Brazil you are in serious
trouble in the bad old days governments
just banned languages they didn't like
but sometimes the pressure is
any teenager growing up in the Soviet
Union soon realized that whatever
language you spoke at home mastering
Russian was going to be the key to
success citizens of China including
Tibetans as well as speakers of
Shanghainese or Cantonese faced similar
pressure today to focus on Mandarin once
the language is gone well it usually
goes the way of the dodo just one
language has ever come back from the
dead
Hebrew it was extinct for two millennia
but Jewish settlers to Palestine in the
early 20th centuries spoke different
languages back in Europe and they
adopted Hebrew on their arrival as their
common language it became Israel's
official language when the country was
fully established in 1948 and now has
seven million speakers now Hebrew is the
world's only fully revived language but
others are trying Cornish spoken in
southwestern England died out two
centuries ago but today there are
several hundred speakers of the revived
language practicality aside human
diversity is a good thing in its own
right
imagine going on an exciting holiday
only to find that the food clothing
buildings the people and yes the
language was just the same as back home
all of our Wendell Holmes put it well
every language is a temple in which the
soul of those who speak it isn't
shrunked moving that soul of the people
from a temple into a museum just isn't
the same thing
you